- Here's my question, cause
like people watch reality TV
and I'm like, how real is reality TV?
Because there's cameras there.
So that's not real, right, so.
- Well, listen, here's
what the good and bad part.
So I'm on season one, so
I didn't know any better
than to just act myself.
I didn't know, I didn't know.
- Oh please keep doing that,
don't be weird, like the other
- I didn't know how much of
it would be on TV or whatever.
I mean they said okay, ignore the cameras,
just go about your daily business,
so you know I went
about my daily business.
I was on the bidet, I'm getting into my,
you know, my man spanx.
(laughs)
Little did I know, wait a
minute, wait a minute now.
Little did I know, that this
was going to end up on TV.
(laughs)
- Oh my god, I actually
want to be such good friends
with you, like the fact
that you did, that is,
I talk about my spanx
all the time so openly,
It's so great.
- Yeah, but I'm a man.
- Who cares?
- And you know what, here's the thing
- I know men that wear spanx.
- Well, now I know.
Listen, I didn't know
that the spanx community,
for men was like, like once you say
- That was underground.
(laughs)
- It was easier to come out as a medium
than as a spanx man.
- It was easier to come out
as medium than a spanx man.